let me hit with this comment that
somebody posted here on Twitter when I
shared the uh topic for tonight's show
and we're going to be doing some q a as
well moth's in The Green Room he's going
to be um making sure you guys are
squared away and your audio is good I'll
drop the link to join in a little bit
but one of the fellows on Twitter said
uh Ross was his name he said if guys
didn't use money to impress girls they
wouldn't have such a problem if you want
to avoid gold diggers then stop showing
them where to dig
and in theory that is a good idea but
look maybe if you're a younger guy I
could see a little more care being used
in the way you go about life but look I
mean when you've made it when you've
when you've done something with your
life when you've gone somewhere you're
not gonna buy a crappy car if you're a
car guy just to have a crappy car
because you're afraid of gold gold
diggers and you're trying to hide it
um she's going to find out eventually
anyway she's gonna know if you're made
of more than just you know a Toyota
Camry
um it's going to become evident it
should be and I don't think that you
should have to hide it to be honest with
you
um I think that dealing with the right
kind of check and setting the right kind
of boundaries is a better way to go
about it but hiding your stuff for women
I remember I watched this uh dating show
once it was one of those like
millionaire match shows and there was
this guy that owned a junk company
and um you know this Matchmaker sets up
the couple's
um with uh you know successful men with
beautiful young attractive women sort of
thing that's a Matchmaker service and he
was all about I don't want to flaunt my
wealth and he did quite well he owned a
junk removal company and on his first
date because he didn't want to pull up
in his nice car or his exotic car he had
a few cars he decided to take one of the
junk removal garbage trucks on the first
day and the Matchmaker of course said
what are you stupid right like what are
you doing
um so people go a little bit too far
with this trying to hide or to or to
dissolve or to make it uh a little more
downplayed and I don't think that's a
good strategy and I'll explain why in
this um you know when we do this segment
and by the way guys if there's something
you want to challenge me on on this show
you don't agree with me uh you have a
better solution
um you can click the join link and you
can hop in and I'd love to hear what it
is
um it's always fun to deal with uh more
than just agreeable people from my
perspective anyway so I've got a few
notes here that I want to cover
um
I'm not really sure which one I'm going
to start with so I'm just going to rip
through them
I think the first thing that you want to
do is make sure that you're not leading
with your wallet when it comes to
dealing with women when you're dating so
so if the question becomes how do you
protect your wealth from gold diggers
you should probably not lead with your
wealth right uh don't be one of these
like sugar dad dudes don't uh hey I'll
take care of your allowance and we pay
you stuff whatever any of those things
you're basically starting from a
position where you're beta bucks
um which kind of brings me to another
Point as well that I need to cover
there's generally speaking there's two
types of guys that women look for or
date they would ideally like them both
in one guy but it's not always possible
so it's why they have like this
dualistic mating strategy the stating
the sexual strategy whatever you want to
call it and there's the alpha C
component and then there's the beta need
component the beta box part of the
equation so
the guy that's been incarcerated in jail
for four or five years doesn't have a
pot to piss in or a window to throw it
out of uh maybe has a old 20 year old
motorcycle Harley or something like that
he has no trouble getting girls he has
no trouble getting late it's no trouble
getting the attention of women because
he's a bad boy Alpha archetype right
they're not using him for his financial
resources there's probably another guy
that they're using for his financial
resources that's the alpha and then
there's a beta
um
I was just watching before I hopped on
the show a documentary series on Anna
Nicole Smith uh if you don't know who
she is she was a very attractive Playboy
playmoy Playboy Playmate from I think
she
she ended at 97 or 87 it was it was well
over 20 years ago but she basically met
this billionaire oil tycoon guy in Texas
uh older dude well into his 80s uh who
had lost his wife and she was working in
his strip joint at that time and he took
care of her bought her a house looked
after her kid bought her horses cars all
kinds of stuff and uh she then said to
him you know when he asked her to marry
him she said I don't want to because I
want to make something on myself first
so she started running around
and she had beta bucks as the backup
okay she met this guy when she was quite
young and from what I understand I
haven't watched the rest of it but I'm
pretty sure she married the guy later on
in life because she died around 39. but
she made something out of herself
running around uh she was the guest girl
she did Playboy spreads she did a couple
of movies
um dated athletes uh actors businessmen
like anybody that was the alpha C part
of the equation because she eventually
did fall back on beta bucks which is the
billionaire oil tycoon guy who's the old
man there's a funny picture here let me
see if I can dig it up here there's a
really funny picture of them I think
it's on their wedding day
um
let's let's go there it is wedding day
so he was 89.
uh present share screen
okay this dude over here he's just beta
bucks all day long
um he was 89 at the time
anyway
um that's what that looks like so
leading with your wallet is going to get
you in a scenario where you're this dude
now I'm not really sure what happened at
the end of story I've watched the rest
of it maybe she inherited his wealth
maybe her kid did I have no idea but you
have to understand that notion because
if you don't have any money and you're
the alpha C part of the equation
you don't have any money to protect you
don't have any wealth to protect it
doesn't really matter so there's that to
consider but do not lead with your
wallet if you lead with your wallet in
the equation you're going to end up like
this Jay Howard Marshall dude uh who
gave away probably pretty much
everything to to her and and the kid and
the breakup or when she passed
um so don't leave it with the wallet we
talked about office seed but you need
don't live in a way
that looks like marriage to the state
very simple
um if you're in a long-term relationship
and you want to protect your wealth and
you don't want to have to deal with any
consequences down the road look any
professional that I talk to and I have
this you know I have these questions
that you know that I generally have with
licensed professionals that I deal with
so I obviously deal with lawyers I have
a family lawyer I have corporate lawyers
I was uh I had lunch today with my
accountant and you know one of the
topics that always comes up is marriage
and you know it was it was tabled do you
see any point in marriage
um later on in life and the answers
always know every single licensed
professional out there that deals with
finances that deals with the law that
deals with accounting they're like no so
one of the Simple Solutions that all of
these people basically have in their
mind is just don't live in a way that
looks like marriage to the state and
you're completely fine right
um what does that look like where you
live I don't know check with family law
um if you're going about your business
you're you know you're working you've
got some some cash coming in maybe
you've got some Investments you got some
money
it wouldn't be a bad idea if you're out
dating and you know you're getting
serious with somebody to talk to a
family learn to go all right well what
is it what does the law say in my state
when it comes to assets and wealth uh
because if you don't know this already
um I'm not going to pull up the list
because I can just talk about it but
um the
richest people in the world of all of
the folks that are listed on that
billionaire list
all the women
that are on the list I think with the
exception of one which was a business
tycoon but all the women on that list
that ended up on that list ended up
there
either through inheritance through their
father or through divorce
um Mackenzie Bezos was recently divorced
from Jeff Bezos a few years ago and I
believe she got 38 billion in stock if
I'm not mistaken she ended up getting
married with one of her kids private
school teachers I think was a chemistry
teacher or something like that and you
know she's she's got her wealth from
Jeff Bezos now from from the Amazon pot
she keeps 38 billion gets married to
this guy that doesn't work out she
leaves she still keeps the 38 billion
because she knows how to get the money
and she knows how to keep the money so
all you have to do is take some
intentional steps and take a look around
when you're dealing with
uh romance and women stuff like that and
yeah I know guys it takes the win out of
the sales it's so unromantic blah blah
blah look
if you don't like it and I'm probably
talking to the ladies at this point but
if you don't like it get the gals
together go down on Parliament Hill you
know whoever it is that makes these laws
you know the bureaucrats where you live
and tell them we don't like these laws
they suck my boyfriend won't live with
me because family law is going to take
half his [__] and give it to me if I
want to take it but they'll never change
that the girls will not march on Capitol
Hill they won't do anything to change
the laws because why would they it's to
their benefit for them to exist so what
smart guys do because they just all
right I'm just not going to live in a
way that looks like marriage right so
talk to a family lawyer about that
that's that's a safe test there's of
course guys right now going to be in the
comments just stay away from women okay
that's one solution
um it's not realistic when half the
population is women and guys like women
and you know men and women are generally
speaking Better Together than they are
apart
um you just have to be Discerning in
your tastes and who you invite in your
life and all these things which brings
me to another thing when it comes to
Discerning taste is
the red flag chapter
um I wrote this book if you guys are new
to the channel that this is what the
podcast is based on okay the unplugged
Alpha book I'm currently working on the
second book it'll be out later on this
year towards the end of the year there's
a chapter in the book called 20 Red
Flags uh I'll put the ticker up on the
bottom for those of you that are newer
to the channel
get on my email list
I don't even care if you don't buy the
book get on my email list and get the
book for free there
the more I talk to guys on consoles okay
the more I realize the significance and
the importance of vetting for red flags
um you can invite women into your life
with these 20 red flags I've added a
21st red flag which will be in the
revised version of the book
which I'll talk about another time but
these 20 red flags that are currently
existing in it
are extremely important
and you can Overlook them you can ignore
them you can invite a woman into your
life that has them you can put a baby in
her you can get married you can live
together
and maybe things will work out maybe
but on a balance of probabilities if I
was a Gambling Man and I and I could bet
on that relationship failing it probably
will and it'll probably fails sooner
than later if it doesn't it'll at least
be miserable for one or both of them at
the same time this red flag chapter is
so important and the significance of it
matters so much when it comes to dealing
with women I can't even emphasize it
every time I have a consult with
somebody privately every time I do I'm
always diving into this and we're going
back in it we're going back and forth
and we're chopping up sometimes I have
longer term coaching clients sometimes
it's a one-off call
but every time there's problems in that
relationship there's always red flags
that pop up now if you've got money
issues you're dealing with a woman
that's you know promiscuous for example
she's been with 50 100 dudes or
something like that
do you think she's gonna stick to you if
there's conflict later on down the road
after she's living in your house she's
moved her [__] in maybe you guys said I
do together you took a honeymoon and
she's been with all these dudes and
something doesn't work out do you think
she's going to stick around the
probabilities of that happening are
pretty low the probabilities of her you
know maybe picking up her phone and
start dialing some other dudes Dialing
for dick off her her phone is a lot
higher because she's already done it
you know 98 times 99 times 100 times
doesn't matter what it is it's already
been done so it's very easy very very
comfortable for them and that's you know
we're talking about a lot of other stuff
than just women that are misbehaved in
their past or have promiscuous past
right so without me getting into the
entire chapter vet against the red flags
and don't do it over a short period of
time don't just be like oh okay well you
know I was with her for 10 months so I'm
pretty sure that I figured her out the
rule of thumb and this is not my rule of
thumb this is a rule of thumb that was
given to me by a psychologist
do I have his book over here tactical
guide to women Shanti Smith he said see
what they're made of date him for a year
and a half two years because you end up
with a representative most of the time
you end up with an actor and you don't
know who the real person is wait till
you get sick but you take care of you or
does she just leave you be
deal with it man cold [__] right or
does she take care of you does she
expose her own immune system to risk of
getting sick as well to take care of you
right how does she handle uh when the
luggage gets lost if you travel
somewhere together does she have a
complete meltdown and a spaz and wants
you to sue the airline and yell at
people or as you say let's just go take
a cab to the store and get a couple of
bathing suits and some stuff to tie us
over until we get back and they find it
or it shows up right
it's important to give it time so get on
my email list if you're not on it get
the red flag chapter if you haven't got
it or read the book uh which is an even
better way to approach this because some
of the other stuff that I'm talking
about here also deals with
components around
um dealing with the struggles that comes
you know with the red flags and what
genuine burning desire looks like so
I'll move on from the red flag so I can
keep this thing going
try to I'll try to get to the bottom of
my list in the next uh 10 minutes or so
so we can take some call-ins anyway
speaking of Collins guys I'll grab the
join link for you guys
um and just drop it in the chat
right here on YouTube call in and ask me
a cue
and stream yard link you'll get them off
in the green room and he'll make sure
your audio is all good and you're good
to go so I'm going to pin that at the
top of
um the YouTube channel
so head over there if you're not
watching that from that angle
um let's talk about genuine burning
desire
um
all women want to be with a competent
man that can make it rain okay so the
argument that there's no gold diggers
doesn't exist you can call them whatever
you want but women want to be with a
competent man they want to be with a
giant they want to look up to they won't
they don't want to be with a wimp they
don't want to be with a guy that can't
solve basic things
in your lives in your in your household
a guy that has to call you know his dad
or she has to call her dad to solve
every little problem they don't like
that kind of stuff
she has to have a genuine organic
burning desire for you just to want you
just to physically want just to desire
you okay if that is absent and all
you're doing is you're leading with your
wallet of course you're going to track
gold diggers okay the woman that has
genuine burning desire for the guy
is still interested in his financial
resources but the genuine burden desire
that she has for him is because she
looks up to him she sees him as a champ
she sees him as a strong option or maybe
even her best option genuine burning
desire is very very hard to ignore it's
obvious it's it's as obvious as taking a
frying pan to the forehead as they say
okay people sometimes say to me Rich
what does January burning desire to look
like how do I know that that she's got
it for me right
simple test you know if you want to test
you can test if you want you know simple
test might be something like um
hey you know before you head over
tonight do me a solid head over to the
liquor store and get me that uh bottle
of whatever that I like okay no problem
you want the 40 answer or do you want
the 20 answer that's a that's a strong
response that's a woman that's got
interested you you know she wants to
make you happy she wants to please you
if she's like I don't buy no [__] for no
man that that that's she doesn't have
genuine burden desire for you right I'm
not paying for stuff she doesn't have
genuine or desire for it a buddy of mine
told me about this uh coffee test one
time I'll recap it it's it's in one of
my older videos
um
and he ran across it by accident because
he accidentally forgot his wallet when
they were out and he wanted to get a
coffee and here in Canada we've got Tim
Hortons everywhere if you're not
familiar with Canada called Timmy's
and said to his girl he said you know
Jimmy saw can we just go through the
drive-through I want to grab this uh you
know this medium coffee you know just
grab me a double double I forgot my
wallet she had a freaking meltdown a
legitimate meltdown on him because he
didn't have his wallet on him and a buck
50 or whatever would have cost him at
the time she had a serious meltdown over
the whole thing now
a smart guy would have just walked away
from that relationship and said whoa
look I like you know thought in his head
look I've taken you out to dinner we've
had a good time you were on my boat the
other day sort of thing
the dumb guy would just proceed with the
relationship and take the beating right
a woman that's got genuine burden desire
for you but whatever a buck 50 who cares
what do you want you want whipped cream
on it you want some peppermint too no
problem
I'll get it for you you want me to shake
my bum while I walk away she'll do that
too right that's what a woman will do
when she when she digs revive that much
okay genuine burn desire must exist if
you're not familiar I think that's
chapter three in my book
you should recap it
the rules is chapter two and yeah why
genuine burning desire matters number
three there's actually a video on my
channel if you go back to the
entrepreneurs and cars Channel
um just type in why genuine burning
desire matters and you'll probably get
it it's it's a very very old video it's
an early one from about four or five
years ago
and it's why it ended up in the book I
expanded on the on the concept in the
book for you guys as well just so you
understand it
um what else can we talk about don't get
married if you well let's talk about
marriage
um look if you want to raise a family
it's far better to do it than a
two-parent household whether you get
married or not is your choice doesn't
matter to me I don't really care I'm not
a big fan of inviting the state into my
life you guys know that I'm a
Libertarian I don't want them in my
pocketbook I don't want my bank account
I don't want them telling me what to do
and the truth of the matter is you have
responsibility and authority and those
things should be connected in a
household when you're building a family
and a life together sort of thing but
today in most western provinces and
states you still have responsibility but
you've lost the authority when Family
Law gets involved they get to tell you
what to do and guys don't really
understand the significance of it until
they've been through the divorce grinder
or they know somebody close to them a
brother a sibling a cousin very good
friend that's been through the divorce
grinder that can offer some feedback and
some ideas around it but a very simple
you know solution is just don't get
married if you do because it's part of
your cultural belief system family
insist on it fine
if you're in a far better position than
she is which exists
some of the time maybe it's most of the
time you know some guys would argue but
if you're in a far better financial
position meaning let's just say you're
worth 5 million and she's worth a couple
hundred thousand dollars it's a smart
idea to get a prenup oh that's
unromantic you're basically setting up
the marriage for you know for divorce
you don't you don't trust her oh what
you don't you don't trust me sort of
thing
um it takes the win out of the sales
blah blah blah yeah it does sure it does
absolutely but again I don't see women
getting together and marching on Capitol
Hill saying that our men won't marry us
because family law could potentially Rob
them of their wealth and their access to
their kids and be alienated and all the
potential problems that come on later on
down the road so if you're going to get
married and you're in a far better
position get a prenup if you're not it
doesn't matter it's not relevant right
um they lose value over time so you guys
met at University you go to law school
you both become lawyers at respective
different law firms you're making about
the same money you probably don't need a
prenup because you're making about the
same money you've probably got about the
same masses right it's not necessary
it's it's it's a protective mechanism is
all that it is those would be the main
ones that I would encourage you guys to
contemplate I've just spent about 22
minutes going through all those I think
they're pretty clear at this stage and
for the guys that run away for women oh
they're all evil or they're difficult or
it's impossible in the west I call
[__] on that
um I've look I'm obviously a little more
seasoned than some of you guys watching
this tonight
been in a long-term relationship with my
gal she's great
um we get along really really well like
99 of the time obviously nothing's
perfect obviously but setting certain
boundaries following certain guidelines
vetting women for red flags not inviting
crazy into your life you know I had a
conversation
um recently last week and I think it's
important to note this before we switch
to the call-in segment is
don't ever confuse
crazy in love because a lot of the times
crazy can look like love when it comes
to how you interact with women
um if if she's doing off-site stuff if
she's got a lot of red flags but at the
same time she's like taking care of you
when you're sick love bombing you
messages you know all day you know uh
doing all the crazy stuff in the bedroom
sort of thing don't confuse Crazy For
Love Again watch for a good year year
and a half to see what she's made of see
if she deals with stress what happens if
a luggage gets lost when you travel
stuff like that that's when you'll see
the real person so you have to be very
very careful because a lot of times for
some guys if they're not good at being
very clear with red flags and setting
strong boundaries is crazy can look like
love so just be careful with that I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out